so Arianna welcome to Stanford thank you
so much what a fabulous auditorium we
hadn't picked them specifically so you
often quote a Persian poet who
encouraged us to live our lives as
though they were rigged in our favor now
whilst it's often easy to proclaim the
fact after after success it appears as
though you actually embodied this
mindset from an early age but not just
you your parents - so it's wondering if
you could take us back to Greece where
it all began and share with the audience
the story as to how your parents met and
how they came to be in Greece well first
of all Nev thank you so much for
starting with my favorite quote which I
carry with me laminated in my wallet and
which I I keep bombarding my children
with in fact my oldest daughter
Christina is here so she's heard it many
times and it really did all start with
my mother because we you know we lived
in a one-bedroom apartment in Athens
Greece and and one day I saw a picture
in a magazine of Cambridge University
and I said to everybody who could listen
I really want to go there and everybody
said don't be ridiculous you know you
don't speak English we don't have any
money and it's really competitive to get
into Cambridge even if you are an
English girl but my mother said let's
see how you can get there and that
involved going to the British Council
and taking my GCSE which as you know
since you're an Oxford girl is what you
need to take as the first step and
borrowing money and then one thing which
are kind of love is that she said one
day I got of these cheap tickets and we
can go and see Cambridge it was it was
kind of an early visualization trip
we're not going to see anybody at
Cambridge we just were going to see
Cambridge and kind of make it more real
for me that I could go there and to cut
a long story short I i got an exhibition
with it which is kind of a scholarship
with version and the scholarship I
remember getting that telegram saying
awarded exhibition and I had to find out
what the hell was exhibition to
Cambridge and that definitely changed my
life it was kind of the the unexpected
trajectory that made a lot of other
things possible especially because I
fell in love with the Cambridge Union
the debating society and I really really
put a lot of my energy into learning to
speak and whenever anybody says well I
can't speak or I'm terrified of speaking
apparently public speaking is in terms
of fears higher up than death by
mutilation so this is no good for me
right now then okay so I started you
know literally by writing down every
word that would be called in sometimes
after midnight and because I was so bad
and also at this heavy accent which was
accent so good well maybe now maybe in
America but you know perfectly well not
in not in England anyway so sir
you gotta take whatever card you can
play I'll take the British accent here
so I spent an enormous amount of time at
the Union in fact I spent more time at
the Union then I spent studying which is
why you got a first at Oxford and I only
got it to one okay and that's why you're
sitting in that chair and so so on that
point so in in thrive you one of your
best-selling books you talk about having
this inner voice that's an obnoxious
neighbor and yet from the outside you
look as though you have this remarkable
self belief because you not only went to
Cambridge but despite the glorious
accent you decide to run for president
at Cambridge and became the first
foreign lady or foreign lady at all to
become president that continued
thereafter whereby after your first
successful book your next one was
rejected 36 times before and then even
with the Huffington Post you launched it
to a backdrop of critics
so this perseverance appears to be a
common thread throughout your journey
how much of that spun from Drive of
being the underdog or was it a mindset
that you taught yourself over time
well I'm it was a mindset that was very
much something that my mother kept
talking about you know one of her
favorite saying was failure is not the
opposite of success it's a stepping
stone to success but the obnoxious
roommate that voice of doubt and self
judgement remained very loud and you
know people don't write about it but I
can tell you I can still hear it I can
still hear for example when I gave my
first big speech at the Union what they
call to this they call it a paper speech
meaning meaning that you actually are
one of the main speakers as opposed to
somebody they call on after the main
speakers and I was speaking
on the same side as JK Galbraith against
William Buckley and I remember every
detail and that the topic of the speech
was the market meaning the free market
is a snare and a delusion and our
sitting next to Galbraith and while
Berkeley was speaking God breath leaned
over to me and said can you stand up you
you have the right at the Union to stand
up and every speaker has to give way for
it the point you want to make so can you
stand up he said and interrupt him and
make it and he mentioned some kind of
recondite econometric point which I
stupidly stood up and interrupted
Buckley with and then he turned to me
and said well madam I don't know what
market you patronize and brought the
house down and I said I'm feeling
completely humiliated who should have
been neither here nor there except the
obnoxious roommate for the next week I'm
not exaggerating was replaying that
incident as though this was the end not
just of my career but my life
and and looking back of course it was
none of the above but that's what the
obnoxious roommate does you know and it
kind of basically tears you apart and
I've had so many experiences like that
where it all my energy would be absorbed
in listening to that voice and and
that's why I've spent a lot of time in
my life trying to evict the obnoxious
roommate from my head and I'm doing a
pretty good job now but it took many
many years and and and it changes your
life when you don't have to waste your
energy dealing with that voice but you
can actually go on with your life and
recognize that sometimes things are not
going to go well and sometimes you're
not going to perform at your best and
that's part of life it's funny you say
that because then I've read somewhere
that you appear to be in your own person
from a very young age would you mind
sharing the story about your fifth
birthday party oh yes I always love to
read I love to lose myself in books
and so for my fifth birthday party my
mother had invited my best friends and I
told him they had to go home because
they were interrupting my reading well
it's clearly a passion and although you
know you've written 15 books to date now
across a wide variety of topics it seems
to be politics that that's kind of
captured your attention the most what is
it that drew you to the political sphere
especially in the discussion and
commentary side so it was politics as
the Dean mentioned you know the the
third world America book was was very
much sort of my deep concern about what
was happening in the country and how we
are not paying sufficient attention and
that remains a very deep concern of mine
but I I now feel increasingly that the
thing that we are most starved for in in
our political lives as well as the rest
of our lives is wisdom and I feel that
we are kind of drowning in data and
starved for wisdom and so my passion now
is how can we connect with that part of
ourselves that is the wisest part of
ourselves and whether we are politicians
or business leaders or media leaders
there are huge problems in front of us
and if we don't connect to that part we
are going to be operating and making
decisions from the surface and as a
result missing the opportunity to really
come up with big solutions and I I was
fascinated by how leaders that we admire
throughout history have done that in the
past like one of my favorite stories
that I've included in my new book is
about FDR when he was in 1940 where
there was all this pressure on him to
enter the war but the American public
was completely opposed to it so he
didn't literally he didn't know what to
do and what
she did would never have happened today
he took ten days off and went on a naval
ship around the Caribbean and Eleanor
would send him letters saying things I'm
so happy to think of you sleeping and
refueling and his aides afterwards have
written how he truly refueled and in the
process of refueling he came up with
what was a political masterpiece of a
solution the lend-lease program that
allowed America to enter the war at a
time when otherwise public opinion would
have been completely opposed to it and I
think we all need to do that and we need
to validate people who do that as
opposed to judging politicians who go on
vacation now who play golf or who do
anything to refuel and therefore ideally
come up with the solutions that are
really at the heart of leadership it's
interesting because then some may say
that the reason that doesn't happen is
because of this 24/7 media commentary
and increasingly it's it's thought and
in some circles that media is
increasingly shaping politics as opposed
to just reporting on it so how do you
think through and try and control that
with your curation and editorial prowess
I think I mean it's our fault right some
they say certainly not myself but some
so I think we first of all we are not
going to avoid the 24/7 nature of media
and the internet this is whether you use
even if you never go on The Huffington
Post or the New York Times site or any
site you know you have your Facebook and
Instagram and endless social media so
that's going to be the nature of our
lives going forward so that's why it's
even more imperative that we learn to
set around boundaries and that we need
to stop giving in to
they're too formal you know the fear of
missing out we know that is because in
the end what we're missing out on is our
life and and that is something which
will require a major culture shift I
mean we can do it individually and a lot
of people are doing it and ironically
there is now more and more technology
that paradoxically is helping us deal
with technology but in the end it will
require some support from the culture
whether it's culture at school at
college and in the workplace is where we
are in our families so I feel that we're
in the process now of a major culture
shift and we're in the middle of this
transition and like any other transition
a lot of different types of behavior are
valued and are exhibited all at the same
time and whether you're optimistic or
pessimistic depends on what you focus on
so this fourth revolution has been a big
topic at Davos and amongst many of the
world leaders and you know you ran for
governor California once but haven't
returned to politics directly yourself
what caused you to run then and why not
since and would you like to bring about
the fourth resolution oh no I have I I
would rather have him five hour root
canal I mean there are very few things
that I can categorically say but I would
never run for office is one of them
which I'm sure Cristina my daughter will
be happy to hear she was very opposed to
my running in the first place I I would
never run first of all because I feel I
can I can contribute more with what I'm
doing and secondly because politics at
the moment is completely poisoned and I
think that's one of the problems that
really it's we got to the point where
anybody who can do anything else was
is not going to enter political life
anymore so we definitely need to change
the system so that we can bring in
better people to run but but I am
definitely not going to be one of them
maybe you if you decide to so it won't
certainly do without me bumbling along
and making a mess of things but um okay
so let's talk about the the platform
from which you you're currently able to
to shape you the Huffington Post
so you establish this back in the day it
was a revolutionary online platform mix
of original content irrigation and
blogging yet you were at the time
neither part of the media establishment
nor a common man that the the bloggers
represented nor a tech person so how did
the idea come about and how did you get
it off the ground initially so the idea
really came about because I could see
that the conversation was moving online
and and I wanted to sort of elevate the
online conversation because as you said
at the time bloggers were perceived as
people who couldn't get a job in their
pajamas in the parents basement and I
will demonstrate that in fact it could
be different and so from the beginning
my aspiration for half was remember we
started with five people out of my home
in Los Angeles but my basement in the
basement a rather nice office but still
a tiny operation but the goal was to
ultimately become both a journalistic
enterprise of the kind that we did
become we now have 850 reporters editors
engineers in 15 countries we want a
Pulitzer so to become a really
substantive journalistic enterprise but
what would be a platform and that was
just as important from the beginning and
and on day one I had an amazing roster
of bloggers I had emailed everybody I
knew and had said if there is anything
on your mind that you want to write
about it please write about it on the
Huffington Post and we're going to make
it super easy for you I know all of you
could be writing for the New York Times
because you know I invited people like
Larry David and Ellen DeGeneres and and
just how long ago it was so many of them
are dead now Walter Cronkite and and
basically we had this amazing first day
when a lot of these people everyone I
just mentioned was on the first day of
The Huffington Post blogging so suddenly
blogging was elevated into something
which you could do even though you could
actually write an op-ed that would be
accepted in the Financial Times or the
New York Times and the reason why they
would do that is because it was so much
easier they would just write something
and we would post it and they wouldn't
be edited and they wouldn't go back and
forth asking them to make it shorter or
longer or whatever and in fact we
created a little concierge service where
people in LA could literally dictate
they could call us from the fall from
their cars and we would take dictation
and then send it back to them to make
any edits and I think we re David
everything he wrote he would dictate
from the set our Emmanuel would I
remember call me from the golf course
they have this idea about Mel Gibson
it's terrible that Hollywood isn't going
against him remember when he made his
anti-semitic comments and Hollywood was
giving him a pass and literally re
called me on a Sunday I took dictation I
sent it back to him he made a couple of
changes we posted it and he changed the
climate in Hollywood suddenly Disney
announced were not going to be doing his
next movie etc etc so people began to
see the power of blogging and the power
of just Express
singen opinion having it up immediately
we had from the beginning our comments
were pre moderated because I wanted to
keep a civil environment and avoid ad
hominem attacks because I felt like I
was inviting these people to come to my
home and express the views and I owed it
to them that nobody was going to
suddenly start trashing them and we had
no were very money we started the
Huffington Post with 2 million dollars
which I collected from my friends and my
partner Kenny lair collected actually my
first investors where Lori and Larry
David and when they got divorced you
know they split the Huffington Post
investment and so I remember you know
paying my daughters five dollars each to
moderate comments there in the early
teens and basically we used everything
we could to create from the beginning a
civil environment in which these people
would want to return and probably the
breakthrough moment was when who was the
identity of deep throat was revealed do
you remember that and Nora Ephron was
you know in high demand you know
everybody wanted her to tell her story
what did she know when did she know it
because at the time she was because she
had been married to Carl Bernstein and
so she calls me up and says you know
what I don't want to go to CNN and get
her in makeup and I don't want to have
to bother with a New York Times op-ed
I'm sending you whatever I'm sending you
my blog so the fact that Nora Ephron
chose this new platform to to May to
write something which was then
everywhere made people realize that if
it was something that was newsworthy
they could write on the Huffington Post
and then it would be any everywhere
anyway you know CNN and the New York
Times and everybody would be compelled
to link to it because that was the only
way to get the story
so that is when we really kind of
arrived in a way in terms of people
coming to us too right and that has
remained kind of a big passion of mine
recruiting people interesting voices in
fact I want to invite all of you to
write on the Huffington Post and I
always make it super easy by giving you
my email address so you can email it to
me directly now we give people we trust
passwords so you can post directly and
then our editors front page and social
and we translate the best so my email
address is Arianna our Huffington Post
calm that's one of the good things will
you found the company you get a good
email address so we are now up to a
hundred thousand bloggers and our goal
is to get to a million we are creating
some a lot of new technology that will
make it easier to post and and to
navigate the scientist cetera it's not
getting sleep after five hundred six
hundred people email you their their
blogs but before I move on just on the
point of the platform given that it was
always meant as this medium for anyone
to share their opinion and voice pretty
much unfiltered what let's the decision
to share your name with it knowing that
your personal reputation will be
associated with the material posted on
the website and how if at all has that
affected the curation process well I was
always like all mean there was never any
question of my separating myself from
the Huffington Post I have to say that
my daughter's begged me now to call it
the Huffington Post
because they thought it was just going
to be an embarrassing failure and they
would not be able to show their faces at
school so I remembered tearful moments
with Christine and Isabella saying you
can't call it The Huffington Post that's
so embarrassing
and Isabella my younger daughter
announced that she wiii never blog so
that that four meters are like saying
i'm marlene this is this is it and and
curation though has always been a very
important part of it like from the
beginning even though the platform was
open we have ground rules like we will
not publish conspiracy theories like you
know if you think 9/11 was an inside job
we're not going to publish it on the
huffington post you know we're not going
to publish a kooky medical theory so we
created certain boundaries that you may
you may disagree with people who are
writing but it's not going to be because
they are insane it's always helpful a
good boundary to have in life in general
so you some of your recent books lament
the lack of surprise and the modern
world and yet a lot of this has arisen
from the fact that our online content is
filtered based on pre-existing
preferences so how do you think through
the fact that some platforms similar to
HuffPost are kind of responsible for
creating this bubble effect and kind of
narrowing our preferences and are you
thinking of ways to introduce there and
dippity again online as browsing once
did well right now actually what is
happening is that the majority of people
don't receive their information by going
to a destination but through social even
the huffington post which is probably
the last big destination site gets now
the majority of our traffic through
social through people posting something
that they read on the huffington post on
facebook or
and tagging their friends so this is
kind of a revolution in how we how we
create a site you know I kind of I try
to convince friends of mine for example
who are starting a new business and are
investing a lot of money and their
website how how useless that is I
actually say to them that he vows
launching the Huffington Post today
there would be no website because it's
all social and I think one of the
reasons why who succeeded at remaining
at the forefront of this business is
because we changed our strategy so three
years ago because I woke up after eight
hours labeling feeling completely
recharged I could see the iceberg that
was about to hit the Titanic and the
iceberg was that people were not going
to be coming to the Huffington Post
directly in the large numbers they were
coming to The Huffington Post directly
we had our operation was being driven
very much around our splashes you know
we we launched the idea of the splash
early on in our in the life of the
Huffington Post which was again very
radical and controversial at the time
because the idea was that you needed to
put as many stories as possible at the
top kind of above the fall to drive
traffic to them and we said no we are
going to announce what we consider is
the most important story of the moment
we may change it ten times in the course
of the day but it created a sense of
drama it made people keep wanting to
come in to come back to see so what's
the big story now and we hired editors
who really knew how to create amazing
headlines that were a little playful and
not conventional one of my favorites was
when Dominique strauss-kahn was arrested
our headline was oMG IMF
and so the the point there was that as
things changed we decided to stop
prioritizing our other front pages you
know we still prioritize the front page
because we still get enough traffic to
it but we start prioritizing the
splashes of what by then we had 70
sections at the huffington post covering
everything from colleges to wellness to
busyness and and editors who spend a lot
of time creating beautiful splashes
which would be seen by fewer and fewer
and fewer people so we build different
teams that instead worked on how to make
content be social and be viral but
here's another thing we discovered you
know normally thing of content going
viral as being cats and skateboards or
cute animals and we discovered that the
content that goes most viral is content
around solutions things that people want
to share yes and and so we have now
focused our coverage in three main areas
you know the first is obviously news and
politics where we take though our own
you know we don't I will consider our
job to take stands you know we don't
consider our job simply to blindly kind
of just write what's happening because
we feel you can get it anywhere now why
come to The Huffington Post if you just
want to know who won the Wisconsin race
you know first of all you have gotten it
from your Twitter feed so for us it's I
mean just one of the most controversial
thing we did that every day that passes
I consider one of our best decisions was
covering at the beginning Donald Trump
in the entertainment section
and then on the day that he announced
that he is proposal to ban 1.6 million a
billion billion Muslims from this
country to start covering him under a
clear and present danger with an
editor's note appended underneath each
story for his name appears that says we
would like to remind our readers that
Donald Trump regularly advocates
violence and his lies is a birther which
people forget people forget that he
still believes Obama was not born in
this country wants to burn 1.6 billion
Muslims a serial liar musashi misogynist
and xenophobe so quite subtle it's very
subtle so basically we have no opinion
of Donald Trump and and really I think
the key here was that in a way you think
how can you cover him balls in
entertainment then under clear present
danger thinking jung-hoon you know
somebody who's both a buffoon and a
danger the two things are not
contradictory and the two of them really
exemplify that fact so that's one bucket
the other bucket is solutions and what
we have a dedicated section called
what's working we brought in a great
journalist from The Guardian Joe
convener to run it and in every area
whether it's business the environment
workplaces will focus on what is working
what are the solutions that are working
and this is the content that goes more
viral than anything it's absolutely
amazing and the third bucket is wellness
so just on that point again a lot a lot
of it even through your Facebook feed
and so forth comes again from your
preconceived tendencies so when certain
articles pop up for example someone
searches I know the immigration crisis
would it not be a case of having on one
side the the story but then on the other
something like and by the way here all
the great immigrants that built America
like Steve Jobs were Syrian and so forth
and having them side by side such that
it's almost put in front
of every reader regardless of what they
search for well absolutely we would be
covering the basics of the story this is
not kind of an alternative to that but
so often media cover the crisis the
problem yeah without also covering the
fact that there are solutions to most
problems that are actually happening
somewhere but they are just not scaled
enough so I know you do a lot of work
here but how do you scale something good
so we feel that by putting the spotlight
on what is working we can help them
scale you know we talked about copycat
crimes
how about copycat solutions so I think
that for us the larger point here is
reimagining journalism so that in
journalism schools right now you are
taught that if it bleeds it leads and of
course if anybody is unfortunate enough
to watch local news you would have
thought the only things going on the
community of burglaries rapes murders
and this is just the choice of the
outlet they think that's the way to
drive people to the broadcast but I
think the fact that now most people
receive their news through social is
changing the dynamic so on the topic of
solutions a lot of your your current
books is around kind of helping us as
individuals become better or what we do
now what many may not know given your
long string of successes is the
continuous stream of personal hurdles
that went on in the background right you
very unfortunately had complications
with your first pregnancy you had a
breast cancer scare I believe you know
had a public divorce or you know within
the family certain issues around
substance abuse and so forth so and yet
you you can't continue to go on and be
successful to what extent was work a
distraction to help get through these
moments and why was it that it took a
literal bump to your head to get you to
kind of wake up reevaluate and now help
us to
avoid that situation in the future sorry
for the question no that's great that's
um I I think that work was never a
distraction because I always kind of
loved my work I think what led to my
collapse in Tron 2007 and my breaking my
cheekbone on the way down was that I had
completely bought into the collective
delusion that burnout was the way to
achieve things that yes and now I'm
exhausted and Adamo I'm I'm kind of
sleepwalking through my life but hey I'm
building the Huffington Post and and I
had the delusion that so many
entrepreneurs have that nothing could be
done except by me and therefore I had to
be up all the time and and driving this
the third baby that I considered the
Huffington Post while my first baby
Christina was on college too with me and
she had asked rightly that I should not
be on my blackberry while we were
together
remember that's 2007 so it was still
blackberry time and and so I would then
when she would go to sleep I would start
working and to cut a long story short I
ended up back at home collapsing but in
a way I feel very very grateful speaking
going back to Rumi and living life as
though everything is rigged in your
favor I honestly believe I would either
be dead or have had a heart attack if I
had continued that way because these
things become cumulative so the price
you paid like he's not obvious right
away it's like things seem to be working
until they stop working and the great
thing about last year was that it was
the year when executive after executive
collapsed and either died or ended up
with a heart attack
most recently the CEO of United Airlines
and if you read his schedule before his
collapse you can see why he's back at
work now but
ended up with him major heart attack the
CEO of BMW collapsed during a press
conference the head of M&A at JPMorgan
Jimmy Lee died on his treadmill and I
mean I could go on and on and what is
interesting is that there's the we've
kind of convinced the world that
exercise and nutrition are important
whether we do it or not we kind of
recognize they're important but the
third leg of the stool is sleep and you
have people who literally put the alarm
on and they wake up exhausted and drag
themselves to the gym which now every
sleep scientist and you have some of the
best here at Stanford who will tell you
it's just a terrible mistake for your
health and for your weight if all you
care about is your weight sleep in don't
wake up sleep-deprived and go to the gym
because your body is going to crave
carbs and sugars in order to be able to
function during the day it's somewhat
ironic that in the valley we have sheer
panic attacks when our iPhone depletes
in energy you down to like seven percent
but the fact that we're charging and
running around from 2% doesn't seem to
affect that is such a great point in
fact if you think of it we do we do take
better care of our smartphones then we
take because as you said I actually
begin to panic at about 13% is your
server gets turned on so I make a travel
with about three portable chargers just
in case and and yet if you had asked me
the day I collapsed arianna how are you
I would have said fine because
exhaustion had become the new normal and
you know now that if you go on Google at
least when I last checked a week ago and
you you type out why am I the most
common autocomplete is why am I so tired
and the second most common autocomplete
was why am I always tired
so I like your your mantra of
encouraging us all to sleep our way to
the top it's not my word credit credit
goes to you and that in obviously it's
all good and well kind of raising
awareness amongst the rank-and-file but
the challenge is the environment in
which we operate so to what extent to
your point around all these CEOs kind of
waking up and literary smelling the
coffee do you think that there should be
an equivalent of The Giving Pledge for
sleep whereby you kind of shame everyone
into getting rid of that social stigma
writing on paper their commitment to
adopt the third metric embody a work
environment which rewards people for
coming in rested also deletes emails
when they're on holiday and you know
gives you taxis to get home at night
when you're sleep-deprived and these are
brilliant ideas I love the the
equivalent of The Giving Pledge let's
talk about that afterwards I think this
is this is really a fantastic idea
because it really we are talking about
the need for a cultural shift and there
are pioneers who are leading the way and
removing some of the stigma when for
example Satya Nadella when he became the
CEO of Microsoft told business insider
that he sleeps for eight hours and could
not be an effective CEO if he did not
that was pretty revolutionary because in
the past and when I say in the past I
mean a year ago before he said it if if
I see even if a CEO was sleeping eight
hours he would never admit it because
the whole idea was the Jon Bon Jovi song
that you know I'll sleep when I'm dead
or you lose you snooze you you snooze
you lose or congratulating people for
working 24/7 which now sleep scientists
will tell you is the Cockney
the equivalent of coming to work drunk
but that has been the prevalent culture
and now I mean actually last week too
late to include it in the book was a
real tipping point and that was McKinsey
study that they extracted part of for
the Harvard Business Review don't know
what they didn't do it for you we will
be staying extremist take which the
title first of all when you saw the
title you would have thought it was from
the onion the title was the proven link
between leader between effective
leadership and sleep and it was
Kohi co-written by the McKinsey chief
Global Learning officer and a woman who
was identified as McKinsey sleep
specialist the idea that McKinsey has a
sleep specialist to teach you not how to
do without sleep but to teach you of the
importance of sleep shows you know that
we are in an amazing zeitgeist moment
and I would be once I stopped kind of
pinching myself I celebrated the fact
that this had happened and reached out
of course to the people who wrote it to
have them write about it on the
Huffington Post which they are doing and
and incidentally the sleep specialist is
now has been hired by Facebook to give
this workshops at Facebook so this is
all an amazing new phenomenon and what I
love about this piece which I highly
recommend is that they walk you through
what happens to the prefrontal cortex
which is where the leadership functions
they're what we call the executive
functioning is housed and how incredibly
degraded they are when you are sleep
deprived and then I was co-hosting
squawk box on Tuesday and I asked mark
mark but one of the good things about
car things that you can invite people
that you want
to bring these messages to the financial
community and I invited Mark Bertolini
the CEO of Aetna because I wanted him to
talk about the new initiative he started
at Aetna the third largest health
insurance company which is he's asked
his employees to track their sleep with
a Fitbit and anyone who gets at least
seven hours a night gets $25 and for
each night and as that's kind of again
an amazing statement by the CEO of a
health insurance company and he then he
has Duke tracking the results and
they're finding a 7% reduction in health
care costs they're all the wellness
problems they have and a 62 minute a
week improvement in productivity so it
really helps dispel all these illusions
that in order to be productive you have
to cut down on sleep so I hope all my
professors are listening because I often
email them saying terribly stories late
overslept that I leave the class was at
3:30 and I was having a nap now I can
just call them here at Stanford if you
had woken up from you now but you can
come and ruin GUI dala their MVP from
the Golden State Warriors
and the conversation is being introduced
by Emmanuel Mignot the head of your
Stanford Sleep Center he's going to talk
about how sleep changed his game and he
has tracked it he has all the data and
he in fact instagrammed himself holding
his MVP while sleeping because he feels
the only cat that because his game so
dramatically improved when he started
getting enough sleep and I loved
pointing to athletes because all they
care about winning so those in Business
School who only care about winning I
hope there's nobody
like that but let's say that's all you
cared about succeeding winning and
deciding to the top
sleep is a performance enhancement oh
yeah well clearly I've been dozing a
little bit on stage because there we
haven't got that many minutes left but I
will turn to the audience for some
questions and there'll be two
microphones roaming with with Cara there
at the back to start great we'll start
with a question from Twitter what do you
think is the future for online content
creation well the future is incredibly
bright I think what's happening now is
that we are all content creators it's
not just publishers who are content
creators anybody can be a content
creator whether you're student and
entrepreneur or a brand
in fact brands increasingly now have
entire departments that are about
content creation and we're talking
earlier backstage about native
advertising for us at the huffington
post native advertising has become a
major source of monetization and and
what we are finding is that we have a
separate department separate from
editorial but informed by the same
beliefs and standards that creates
content for brands we for example made a
very profitable deal with Sleep Number
which is a mattress company with
embedded technology and we have a
dedicated section it is transparently
labeled as a sponsored section but again
as we are discussing backstage that
doesn't stop people from wanting to
consume the content provided the content
is good credible and well produced i
Arianna thanks so much for joining us
and there is an article out today in the
New York Times
playing on the global sorry the growing
wealth disparity in this country that
also says that the richest people in the
United States far outlive the poorest
people this is not necessarily new but
that gap is widening and part of the
reason for this is stress and unhealthy
living habits and so I wonder what
you're doing is you're promoting this
message of wellness including sleep you
know that there are a lot of people who
can't party can and that's not
accessible to them so how do we make
sure that we're not just continuing to
grow this divide where some of us in
this you know those of us in this room
get to be healthy healthy and happy and
wealthy and there are a lot of people
who don't experience those benefits
that's a great question and in fact I
try to cover this in the book and two
weeks ago and we held a clinic out in
Harlem we took over a church and invited
people from the community to come in and
we had a group of doctors dr. oz
actually filmed it and it was an entire
hour on his show last week and to talk
about their health and their sleep
specifically and and what was
fascinating is that the delusions that
we talked about that have permeated the
top have actually permeated also the
bottom of a socio-economic class and
unfortunately with even worse
information being given to them like I
talked to multiple people most of them
significantly overweight and a lot of
them suffering from diabetes and we're
talking about people in their 30s and
40s and most of them told me the same
story I sleep for I have two jobs or I
have
jobs I sleep for four hours a night and
I really blame myself every day because
I'm exhausted and they thought that if
they were a Wall Street high-flyer they
wouldn't be exhausted so that's how they
had interpreted our delusion and and
when I when you when you sort of asked
more questions what would happen let me
just give you one story this was a woman
and in her early thirties was a pastry
chef and a babysitter and she said I
would come home after my jobs and that
was my time to watch my shows so that
was like her reward and what she didn't
realize is that she was shortchanging
herself of the one thing that was free
available and that she desperately
needed and that was sleep so sometimes
she said I would watch for four hours
and then fall asleep with the TV then
the TV would wake her up and then she
said I would be so tired and I could but
yet I couldn't go back to sleep so I
would go and have something sweet to eat
so the vicious cycle was perpetuated so
the first I mean there's a lot that
needs to be done you know we need to
raise minimum wage you need to have to
deal with the dangers of you know
technology taking away so many jobs
without people being retrained there's a
lot we can do you know sleep alone isn't
going to solve all these problems but
here is something which is free
available that would dramatically change
the health equation and the resilience
of people who are struggling and so
that's definitely part of of the
campaign that we are running now which
is focusing on these groups and on
colleges and the reason we are focusing
on colleges we're doing sleep fairs in a
hundred colleges and is because this is
the generation it's your generation
that's going to change the culture and
so in these sleep fairs we are as well
as giving a lot of free things that make
that make sleep
including pillows that say sleep your
way to the top we we all sorrowfully
which are available at Stanford all this
week
free uber rides at night a biter yatta
and all you have to do is put the promo
code in if you're in Stanford student
it's a Toyota safety su and the yatta is
offering these because they partnered
with uber and The Huffington Post in
underlining the dangers of drowsy
driving and because what's happened
again part of the culture with with with
drunk driving we've kind of won the
battle the numbers are going
significantly down because people are
much more reluctant to get behind the
wheel when they are drunk but not when
they are drowsy the numbers are going up
so it was 1.2 million crashes last year
an eight thousand deaths so we have a
PSA about it
Travis kalanick and I on tomorrow we are
doing ride alongs with uber driver so
you can actually request us you can the
promo code if you wanna do selfies and
take videos whilst that's having you and
then we we take you where you want to go
do we don't kidnap you
but in this progress you have Travis and
me talk to you about not driving while
drowsy and any other of your bad sleep
habits and we give you a big fabulous
bag with a lot of good I think it's a
very interesting question there because
it's one is kind of almost driven by a
necessity and the others almost like a
privilege choices that we end up in but
certainly we've run out of time Arianna
but I just want to mention as a story as
we close to kind of just share with the
audience how from from dark places come
great things like like Arianna and we
didn't touch it on the beginning but um
the story as to how your parents met and
it was that a hospital in in Greece
where I believe you or your father was
recovering from the Nazi concentration
camp
where he'd been taken as he was a
journalist back in the day and at the
same time her mother was fleeing from
Russia and in there recovering from TB
thinking to never be able to get
pregnant so just a show from despair
come wonderful things like Ariana has
been delightful please join me in
thanking thanking